Speaker 1: let's go next to Justin from New York.
Justin, you're on the air.
Unidentified: Hello, hello.
Oh, can you hear me or. Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: OK, David, how are you? First time,
first time caller, long time listener,
thank you. I have a question, though,
like as I always ask, is that because you don't
have, like, president facts and everything
that are pro vaccination? Well, I always
never really get a good answer for that, like.
What's the end goal like, as if you're not going
to get the vaccination, you're probably going to
get covid Jango just to get coalbed and survive?
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. That's that that's that's
that's basically the review. I mean, have you
asked them what do they say when you ask them?
Speaker 2: They say they literally kind of feel
like, oh, I have them or I'm scared of the shot,
like like, OK, I got well, I got the Johnson one
and that it hurt. Yeah, but the thing is, though,
it's like it's something you do. I was just
trying to make it on my own. I don't know if
you have any like, um, I don't want to censor,
you know, a be worried about it and take it.
Speaker 1: Yeah. When I have a question, when
you say that you got the vaccine and it hurt,
are you talking about the moment they
inject you? It hurts like the little
prick from the needle hurts. Or are you talking
about like later you had arm pain or whatever?
Speaker 2: Yeah, both at the moment don't as a
chopper, you're fine, but then after that, like,
I had armed pain and I had to veivers. But after
after the vaccination. But after that after that,
I was fine. I was just, like, almost sore. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Like, I get that there is there is a
fear of needles and that's a specific thing.
But when people say getting the shot hurts,
I mean, it's literally one second I they put the
shot in is maybe it's three seconds. That part I
don't get like I get the fear of needles that some
people have. That's a widely known thing I get not
wanting to feel sick for a few hours or a day
or two or whatever flu like. But the actual pain
of the shot I don't get because it's under five
seconds. You know, it's that part is strange to me
that that would make someone not get vaccinated.
Speaker 2: Yeah, not only that, but my second
question is, is that like like you have
like I think you probably have like this
question asked many times that I don't
want to repeat it, but you'll have, like,
Republicans who are like, well, like the
Republicans who are against the vaccine mandate,
any measures to really, like, even mask many
measures to mitigate the spread of the virus.
Is it do you think do you think would be a good
political strategy for the Democrats to say these
people, these? These people like Wanda Santos are
like Pokolbin, they're they're they're against
every gay couples that are Prokop that they want.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we've talked about that a little
bit before. I mean, you know, it's really a
rhetorical trick to say that some of these
people are pro covid. I don't think it'll
really catch on very much. But sometimes
I'll say it. It's like some some of these
people or some of the biggest supporters of
the virus that that I've ever seen. I don't
know that it's going to be any big kind of
game changer in terms of getting people to
take things seriously. But you're right.
It's almost like do they are they trying
to spread the virus via their policy?
But I don't think it'll make a big difference
to adopt that as a rhetorical trick.
Speaker 2: All right, thanks
very much for that. All right.
Speaker 1: I appreciate the call. Thank you so
much. Great to hear from you. Some great, great
calls this week. Why don't we go next to Christian
from California? Christian, you're on the air.
Hi, David. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: So I was wondering, with the
big curfuffle made this week from Joe Manchin
coming out and saying he will not vote for the
three point five trillion infrastructure bill.
Yeah. Do you think Manchin overall is is sort of
bad optics for Senate Democrats?
Speaker 1: Well, yeah, I mean,
so so the complicated thing is like, of course he
is, but remember that almost certainly if Manchin
is replaced in Virginia, it's with a Republican.
So he does vote with Democrats on a lot of things.
And it gets us back to this age old, age old
question of, OK, you primary him and he loses,
but then you almost certainly end up with a
Republican. So, yeah, I can't stand the guy.
We predicted he was all of a sudden going to
be front and center in a lot of these policy
decisions. But then you also have to understand
the practicality of West Virginia and who's
likely to replace Manchin. And it's most most
likely going to be a Republican who supports
what Democrats want to do, even less. The solution
is less about remove Manchin because that probably
means a Republican replaces him. It's we've
got to win more seats back in other states.
Speaker 2: And also in Pan with that,
I think we should work on moving Magin
constituents to the left so that absolutely to
vote in a way that reflects the will then and
Speaker 1: also I would say let's try to figure
out a way for there to be political consequences
for Manchin from from being obstinate.
Speaker 2:
Do you think because I do tend to agree with you,
that if you if you ran a progressive type like
AOC candidate in West Virginia, that seat would
probably just go to Republican, right. I mean,
do you think that has more to do with the
right's framing of progressive type Democrats or
like I don't see how you mentioned if
you were to come out aggressively for
this three point five trillion dollar bill,
how would that in any way would harm you?
Speaker 1: No, I completely I on this particular
bill, I totally agree with you. I think
it's less about you know, I do think that I
mean, the problem would be if AOC beats Manchin
in a primary, AOC loses in the general. So it's
really problems that would exist in the general.
I do think it's possible for a sort of working
class type guy, like, for example, Tim Ryan
from Ohio, who's a member of Congress. He's quite
left, but he has kind of like the working class,
middle class creds with regard to his whole
approach. That's the type of guy that if he were
to primary and he doesn't live in West Virginia,
this is just a hypothetical. Tim Ryan, someone
I could see maybe winning an election in West
Virginia at the state Senate level, but I'm not
even sure it's a tough question. It's a tough one.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it is. All right, well,
thank you so much for your time,
David. Enjoy the rest of your day.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it. Yeah. Thank you
so much for the call. It's a good question.
Important to understand the dynamics
there. I mean, very, very important. A